idea
good afternoon councilors like I think
we're just past or just on four o'clock
um so we might make a start so I'll
declare this
ordinary meeting of extraordinary
meeting of Council in session uh we have
a number of items on the agenda to be
considered now that um need to be
finalized before the the end of this
particular Council term
and we have I'm aware of anyway one
apology from councilor Grant councilor D
Grant do we have any others some haven't
heard from Council Davis at this point
so um hopefully she will she will come
so we'll take her as um
uh lateness at this point in time would
somebody like to move that councilor
grants apology would be sustained please
Council Grant thank you
um thank you Stuart thank you
against the motion is carried thank you
counselors
um so a number of items are in the open
session of the council and then we'll
move into in committee
um so firstly Declaration of counselor
conflicts of interest are there any
conflicts relating to today's agenda
that councilors need to declare at this
point
there's not thank you
uh confirmation of minutes confirmation
of the minutes the ordinary meeting of
council held 20 September 22 I was
somebody like to move that be seen as
true and correct Council
um
Reed thank you and seconded uh councilor
Dixon thank you all those in favor
please say aye against
um
the motion was carried thank you
councilors
um minutes of the audit and risk
committee meeting
somebody like to move that that'd be
uh
adopted as well yes yeah so that be seen
as correct and adopted
councilor heisted thank you
double secondary Council mcphail thank
you all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
welcome councilor Davis
we're up to item five and we're looking
at the minutes of the creative
communities assessment committee
would somebody like to move that they'd
be seen as true and correct thank you
councilor Reed
um there was a signature for that
Council house did thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councilors
councilor hosted you look puzzled
that's right just uh would like to draw
their committee council's attention to
the the attached procurement policy that
is part of the recommendation you've
just just moved I think it would be
worth the stepping a quick reference to
that that's attached to the um
is attached to the the minutes okay do
you want to raise the point there this
just so just to draw the council's
attention to it um it's had a couple of
couple of suggested changes um to it
um just around
um conflicts of interest expanding that
to include not only employees but their
spouses partners and family members
that's called 7.3 and also on the
recommendation of our independent member
and also I think um
councilor guardine that when a panel a
quote has received from a panel sorry
when a price is received from a panel
the quoting level has been lifted 8.11
on page 30.
um so you see there that it was an
approved uh purchase uh probably panel
member
um or supplier
um quotes of fifty thousand dollars or
less
um can be just done off one quote that
reflects the the um the market we're in
now an example was given of a pump a
single pump for our water assets
um would would be significantly within
that number so I think the world's moved
on for all of us in terms of these costs
um so yeah
um if it's not part of the the panel um
there will still be um other quotes or
right
apart from that the um
it's pretty much straightforward and
yeah look I assume that everybody's had
the opportunity to read through that and
and understands it and thank you for
raising it um councilor heisted are
there any other issues or questions that
councilors may have with regard to that
procurement policy
before we move on does not okay thank
you right we'll move on to the next item
that brings us to the end of the the
public session of the council this
afternoon
and so with that in mind I would move
that the public be excluded from the
following parts of the proceedings of
this meeting namely the items listed
below
and they are confirmation of minutes
other business minutes the audit and
risk committee partial desludging of the
pond wastewater treatment plant contract
award identification of projects for the
three Waters better off support package
marulaway Center consideration of
tinders hokanui Heritage Trust investing
asset hokanui moonshine Museum trust
operational update and then chief
executive appraisal would somebody like
to second that thank you councilor
Bulger
is there any discussion about that
motion does not I'll put the motion all
those in favor